hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well anger is a common
emotion which we human beings feel
pretty much all of us in fact some
people would say that lacking any sort
of emotional response of anger we might
not even be fully human for Aristotle
anger plays a very important role not
only in an ethics but also in other
venues to the political arena within you
know the workings of the soul he treats
it as a separate cause of human actions
in some other works here were enacting
to concentrate on all that we're mainly
interested in the fairly short nikka
mccann ethics discussion of anger
supplemented by a few things from you
Damien ethics there Aristotle is
primarily interested in the moral status
of anger in terms of virtue and vice is
on different sites so that's what we're
going to explore I think in order to
make sense out of this it's very helpful
to bring in a few things very quickly
from some of his other works so that we
can adequately understand what we're
talking about so what are we actually
concerned with here the feeling of anger
and the responses that it that a person
makes now for Aristotle anger is
is a semi rational emotional response
it's more rational he thinks than sought
the workings of some of the other
passions the pave the the emotions the
desires that we experience and he ends
up defining anger most articulately in
the rhetoric it does have other
definitions at other places and if
you're interested in that you know got
other videos on Aristotle and anger
because I'm working on a book on that he
defines it is a desire for a parent or
public or however you want to define it
could even be imaginary retribution to
Marya literally setting things right or
you might think of it as is re honoring
one self provoked by the appearance of
unjustified sliding to another person
then it goes on a defines with sliding
can mean it literally means putting
somebody down making them lower than
they they they really ought to be
treating them in a way that does not
value them and what's really important
here is the apparent did this turns up
twice there has to do with the response
the the actual action on a person takes
what will count as setting things right
what will count as acting out of anger
and engaging in retribution but also the
cause one doesn't have to get angry at
things that are actually there as a
matter of fact these these vices that
are concerned with this are going to be
in large part a matter of getting angry
for things that are only imagined but
not actually real apparent but not
actually the case so Aristotle thinks
that that anger is a emotion that you
know we all tend to feel and group be
gripped by there are some people who
don't feel it enough he thinks not only
don't act on it enough but don't feel it
enough will come
that in a moment but for the most part
our problems tend to be on this side of
the spectrum from vice of deficiency
through virtue the mean through vices
devices known as plural of excess we
tend to be more over on the outside so
let's think what would it be to feel
virtuous anger well it's not a question
of feeling virtuous anger it's a
question of feeling and acting on anger
virtuously there's a big difference
there it's not anger itself the emotion
itself the response that we feel the
bodily response the psychological
response the actions that we take it's a
exhibition you know in our gestures and
our visit and all those sorts of things
it's not the anger itself that is right
or wrong good or bad Noble or base
instead it's how it is the manner the
time who it's directed at what caused it
is it the right thing there's a lot of
different rights and an aerosol actually
uses this as an example in a quote that
gets used by Daniel Goleman in his
emotional intelligence book to start the
whole book it's difficult to say
precisely how angry a person should get
at what time etc etc going through all
these these rights that means that it's
difficult to pin down rules for this but
that doesn't mean that there isn't some
sort of measure and that there isn't
some sort of habit that people who are
well situated with anger actually fit
into so let's first start talking a
little bit about terminology the word
that we use for this virtue is a Greek
word prowl case and it comes from Prowse
which means something like mild or calm
or gentle something along those lines
and protease is the the substantive of
that the problems would be a person
who's actually
in that case now you can translate that
as good temper you can translate that as
gentle you can translate that as mild
another translation that you might not
realize because it's used in other works
and translating them could be meek when
for example in the New Testament you
know there's these Beatitudes about
blessed are the meek it's the same Greek
word blessed are the prows and when
Moses who you don't normally think of it
as being a particularly quiet guy right
when he's talked about his being meek
it's the same word as well now that
doesn't mean that he doesn't lose his
temper think about it breaks the tablets
right to be mild does not mean that a
person never gets angry it means that a
person gets angry in certain ways at the
right time for the right amount there's
all sorts of sort of limits on it limits
that are in integral not just to some
sort of rule coming in from above but to
what makes a person's life good what
will actually get them towards a network
of good relationships so there's word
I'm going to just use mildness here we
could use all these other synonyms if we
wanted to what is the mild person like
what is their character like what habits
and they built up so Aristotle tells us
a few different things one is that this
person does not act so much from the
feeling but as reason tells them to do
now that that's a very very high
standard so I actually look at this is
you know here's mildness one and then
the other stuff is mildness too but does
not act from the feeling so this person
does feel the feeling but they don't let
the feeling run the show when the
feeling is telling them hey go do that
your ex little talks about anger as
being like a hasty servant that only
listens to half the instructions and
thinks I'm being insulted and then it
goes off immediately to take revenge it
doesn't when your when your reasoning on
the basis of your ammo
you're not really reasoning reason is
has become a slave to the passions to
use a human human phrase right instead
what we ought to be doing is looking at
things even when we were irritated
Aristotle things in a more detached
dispassionate manner and saying yeah
okay this is actually a case where I
want to get angry and I ought to go this
far with my anger and expressing it in
acting on it in in complaining in
punching somebody in the nose you know
all these sorts of things that that
result from maker in yelling another
thing that Aristotle tells us there's a
whole bunch of Rights and this is really
central to having a good disposition
with respect to Inger many people go
wrong by getting angry at the wrong
people you should get angry at the right
people if you're angry because you've
been harmed get angry at the person who
actually harmed you or the person who
caused the situation that resulted in
another person harming you don't get
angry I just at any you know bystander
or the person who points something out
to you or let alone the person who's
actually trying to help you there's a
certain discrimination that's required
here in order to have a virtuous
disposition with respect to anger at the
right time there are some times where
it's really not appropriate to be angry
or to act on anger or to display anger
and it's a sign of an immature selfish
person to indulge themselves in anger
all of the time or you know any time
that they see fit for example i could
get angry at a student within the
classroom and it would be self-indulgent
of me to act on that even if the student
is really being a complete jerk I should
actually try to you know keep in my mind
what are we trying to accomplish in this
classroom what are we trying to get done
here and then talk to the person
afterwards and it's fine to tell them
hey you know you're a jerk not just oh
you know when you act this way you make
me angry the kind of you know
assertiveness training that people
it's okay sometimes to call a jerk a
jerk I think that sometimes when you're
out on the road and you honk your horn
at somebody a lot of people don't like
to honk their horns you're actually
doing a public service because you're
telling that person hey get with it or
pay attention or you're acting like a
jerk and if enough people do that in the
right way to the to the people maybe
they'll change their behavior or at
least think about it but right time is a
key thing right occasion what's making
you angry is this actually a situation
in which you ought to get angry are you
in fact or just apparently being treated
as if you you are of lesser value a lot
of times you know people get angry about
things and then other people say hey
this is just business I treat everyone
this way and then when you realize that
you might say oh yeah I probably
shouldn't get angry about this right
manner how do you get angry this is a
this is a key thing a lot of these vices
over here are gonna have to do with the
how the the manner in which one gets
stays and exhibits angriness you know
right length of time that's a key thing
as well how long should you be angry how
long should you stay angry at somebody
is it dependent on them acknowledging
their fault and doing something to fix
it or are there cases where you you
ought to say well you know this is more
damaging to me to remain angry I'm not
going to get the redress that I want
from this person so I really ought to
for my own sake and for the sake of the
other people got to put up with me being
angry deal with this and and put it to
rest so a key point that Aristotle is
making here is that if a person has a
virtuous dis dis position with respect
to anger they will in fact it angry in
some situations there are some cases
that call for a certain amount of anger
and he's not saying that it's something
you can specify with you know neatly
quantify things you should be
angry at this person for exactly two
days and four hours unless of course
they exhibit this amount of you know
being contrite in that case that will
cut it down fifty percent it's not like
that but there are measures for this and
a person ought to get angry at least as
far as eres level season person wat to
get angry in some cases now the third
thing that he tells us which is
particularly interesting is that the
person who is mild who is a gentle
person who is well tempered is more
inclined to forgive or to let go the
greek word is some good ole may which is
not exactly the same as what you would
see for instance in the Gospels where
it's the different verb that's that's
the basis of that Afiya me to let go
literally but there is some some overlap
between the two of these some granola
may has a more cognitive aspect of sort
of you know thinking understanding being
being perhaps you might even say
empathetic but it doesn't have the
ultimate result of saying yeah okay this
is this is fine I'm willing to to let it
slide it doesn't necessarily mean that
you're a-okay with the person but you're
not going to allow what what they're
doing to necessarily cause you to be
angry and then to lose your temper
enacted an angry way so they're more
likely to forgive than to seek
retribution in situations where a person
would get angry or in cases where they
do get angry that's part of what allows
them to be angry for the right length of
time or in the lack of seeing things get
set right we'll come to these in just a
moment let's talk about the other
extreme that Aristotle in the nick of
mccain ethics actually says well this is
extremely rare as a matter of fact we
don't even have a name for it that's a
pretty extraordinary thing to say and i
think that tells you quite a bit about
about ancient greek society or at least
ancient greek male society that that
Aristotle thinks it was it was so rare
jacques lacan has called Aristotle's
ethics and ethics of masters
and it ignores the fact that a lot of
people did have to sort of suck it up
but you know they they found ways to
also be angry and retaliate as well but
there are some cases and he talks about
this more than you Damian ethics where a
person does not get angry when a person
ought to get angry anger is like we said
before about when a person is being
treated as if they have lesser value or
no value literally being looked down
upon you know they're being made less of
and one gets angry not only on one's own
account but on account of one's wider
network of relationships so one also
gets angry if one's family or one's
friends or ones comrades are being
insulted or attacked or injured or you
know what have you so there are cases
Aristotle would say where a person ought
not only to defend themselves and
getting angry is part of the the process
of defending yourself they also ought to
get angry on account of their mother
their father their children their their
brother their sister their friend being
treated in na in a bad way so this is a
this is a defect of character not to get
angry and not to act on anger when that
anger would motivate you to stand up for
like I put here to stand up for oneself
or for others with with you know whom
one is connected whose happiness matters
to one right or unhappiness matters to
one so he calls this spirited list the
spirited lessness literally lacking
through most lacking the thing that with
is the part of us that gets angry that
gets riled up he also calls it slavish
and it's worth remembering you know
slaves get a very different set of
experiences running an entire gamut some
slaves were treated quite well and
actually
sir sighs quite a lot of power in
ancient Greece and Rome other slaves
were treated horribly you know the ones
who had to work in the mines that's
particularly bad for them and slaves one
of the things that you can say about
them is that they had to just suck it up
so that's that's an you know a way of
thinking about anger there let's talk
now about all these different vices of
excess that I've put over here on the
side I actually don't have all of them
Aristotle he has one other one other
sort of thing that he mentions the
Audrey Roy but I didn't have room for it
and it's not it's not particularly
important it just comes up in the day me
and ethics this is a set of different
modalities of ice with respect to anger
so you know if in fact the virtue he has
to do with all these rights you know
right occasion right people right time
right amount all those sorts of things
when you have a vice it's going to be
some of these in terms of wrongs so
perhaps getting angry too much getting
angry with the wrong person getting
angry at the wrong things staying angry
for too long era so this is something
really interesting he says nobody can
actually compile all the wrongs into
themselves because they would be just
totally deranged that you know it'd be
vice would totally corrupt the person's
soul but there are different ways in
which we humans characteristically go
wrong I don't think that Aristotle
manages to cover everything but he
actually does put together quite a lot
of ground for this so what do we have we
have the irascible the ordeal egri
common way of talking about persons who
had a bad disposition with respect to
hangar and it's coming from the greek
word for anger or gay there's two at
greek words actually through most an
organ they're often used as synonyms by
Aristotle these are people who feel the
emotion of anger far too quickly so
they're they're hotheads they have a
short fuse we
a and so they get angry you know more
quickly than they ought to doesn't take
much to provoke them they often get
angry with the wrong people there's
spillover you might say but Aristotle
comes around right out and says this
he's very explicit about this there is
something good about these people
they're too quick to anger but they're
also very quick once they've sort of
expressed their anger and they don't
necessarily have to express it by
hurting somebody or anything like that
but once they've actually had their
anger it goes away very quickly so he
says that's a good thing they're
hotheads but they also you know are able
to be go back to a normal state fairly
fairly easily these other cases not so
much and these emphasize different
aspects in which we go wrong and stay
going wrong so the Aqua holo the rageful
these are people who get angry very
quickly they get angry for a long time
it doesn't go away as easily Aristotle
doesn't go into very good detail about
this or think you know very deeply about
this but there's something about their
souls and about what they do with their
anger that tends to perpetuate that that
state of being angry you know if you
think for example one of the things they
teach you in anger management is when
you're angry you're making bad decisions
and your reasoning is going to tend to
be often it's going to tend to replicate
the anger so one of the things you
should do is do something unrelated to
what you're angry about unrelated to
anything else go and think about
something else for a while and if you do
that you'll generally calm down unless
you allow yourself while you're out say
taking a walk to think about yeah you
know that was the wrong thing for them
to do and they're always screwing me
around or you know something anything
along those lines anything which is
bringing the anger back up the cause of
the anger the you know I wish I could do
something about this the I'm going to
you know i'll show them next time that I
have an
opportunity that's what the rage will do
I think is you know Aristotle doesn't
say this but I think that's you know
there's resources in his works for
talking about this and in the deion aman
somebody the other works in any case
these people tend to spill over their
anger into all sorts of other things
fairly and appropriately so they start
out being angry about this and now
they're angry about this and now they're
angry about this and they just get
madder and madder and madder that's a
big problem so they are lacking
restraint on their anger on both the
emotion and the expression of it in
terms of a lot of these different
categories then there's the bitter this
is a particularly interesting category
the word that he uses their the peak Roy
is actually the word that's used for
sharp sounds and for bitter taste and
you know people who are bitter and quite
often they're not only bitter about
things that they're getting angry about
now they're all so bitter about other
things that they haven't let go from
before and that's exactly what Aristotle
talks about he says that they keep their
anger in there they're not able to
discharge their anger or they don't
discharge their anger and they keep it
in and because they haven't been able to
do that because they haven't had that
Tim areia that's setting things right
that retribution that reckoning they
remain angry and they remain angry for a
very long time and it starts to burn
within them i would say that
passive-aggressive people actually fit
into the category of the bitter many
people would say yeah passive-aggressive
people they're like the people over here
who don't really express their anger but
they do express their anger they express
their anger in very palpably bitter ways
where you can tell that there's
something going on there beneath the
surface there's more emotion there than
is actually being acknowledged in the
sarcasm
in the context of things and I the
trouble with these people is until they
actually are able to discharge that they
are going to be bitter like that and
once it becomes a habit they can become
bitter about all sorts of things it
becomes something that is difficult to
root out of the soul after a while they
may actually not even understand what
they're they're truly bitter about it
may take something like you know
psychotherapy to be able to to figure
that out finally there's the harsh the
hollow point and halle pining is a Greek
word that is used there's a number of
different Greek words that are used for
getting angry or being angry or
expressing anger oregon's ain coming
from the greek word or gay anger an
octane there's but how Allah paint means
to be like difficult to be it literally
a pain in the butt right to to to make
things rougher than they need to be and
I think harsh is a fairly good
translation of it the harsh refused to
be reconciled without some sort of
retribution they're different than the
bitter in that they're actually looking
for some retribution they're going to
make sure that some retribution happens
but they will not forget they will not
cease to be angry and seems to act in
the way that an angry person does until
they have some sort of reckoning some
retribution that that is okay with them
and generally they're going to be often
in their assessment of what actually
counts as is that so they don't forgive
when when they want to over small things
that's why they're kind of kind of pains
each of these emphasize different
aspects of how we can go wrong with
anger it could be about the things that
we're getting angry about you know we
get it too angry to quickly
indiscriminately for the wrong reasons
with the wrong people or it could have
to do with how well we're able to manage
our
once we actually have it do we actually
exhibit it do we do we deal with it in a
healthy way we kind of like keep it
inside and let it fester do we ever let
it go when we need to are there are
there situations in which we are
legitimately angry but for our own sake
and for the other person and for
everybody else concerned we want to let
it go the virtuous person you know is
the person who is inclined to forgive in
those cases to let it go the harsh
person doesn't do that they insist on
their rights they insist on I have been
hurt or my kid has been hurt I want
satisfaction that would be this case of
being harsh so we've looked now at all
the different things all the different
categories here with respect to anger
Aristotle hasn't organized as he does
with every other set of virtues and
vices into a virtue of the middle vices
on the ends excess and deficiency I
think this one is fairly straightforward
very rich descriptions that he has
throughout running throughout his works
and plenty to think about I think and
reflect upon